[Music]
[Applause]
psycho features one of the most
iconic scenes in cinema history
when the original cycle came out there
had never been anything done like that
and janet lee gave e.t an inside look at
the making of alfred hitchcock's horror
classic
i don't think i did the shower curtain
business any good except the ones that
i've signed
in a time of immense censorship in
hollywood hitchcock found a way to
create
terror using the power of imagination
am i acting as if there's something
wrong the reason that it was so
effectively portrayed was because
at that time we had censorship
everything had to be cleared through a
board and
you could not show nudity you could not
show
graphic violence we all go a little mad
sometimes
so what mr hitchcock did was
bring the audience into the picture so
much
that what they saw their own mind
imagined much worse than you can show
much worse and that's i think was the
secret of psycho
do you go out with friends well a boy's
best friend is his mother
people sophisticated knowledgeable
people
say oh i remember that picture i saw the
blood spurting out and the knife oh and
you know
and of course they didn't see any of it
because we couldn't the
wizardry of mr hitchcock
who could bring you to a point a frenzy
and then let you take off and go up from
there with your imagination
marion's early checkout from bates motel
shocked audiences
as janet only ended up being featured in
a third of psycho
despite being one of the biggest stars
in hollywood it was so funny had the
number of people who came up to me
and said you know we never really
thought that you were dead we
we thought you were you know you would
somehow you got out of the car
out of the trunk and you'd come back in
the picture is that hysterical
while it may seem extreme janet
confirmed to e.t that this legendary
scene made her give up showers forever
it's not pr it is true
i stop taking showers i will not go into
a shower
unless there's no other way to bathe and
then the doors are open i have something
right close by and i'm facing the door
and you know there's no curtain the
floor looks like a swimming pool
but that is the truth the shower scene
became so iconic
it was later featured as part of an
attraction at universal studios
and how about this one of its performers
was curb your enthusiasm star
cheryl hines in my first acting job i
got stabbed in the shower
recreating the psycho shower scene at
universal studios
it was nice i had a flesh colored
bodysuit and then i just
shower in front of hundreds of people a
day and get stabbed
yeah while janet knew hitchcock was
making something special
she had no idea psycho would have the
cultural impact that it did
i don't think in the making of any movie
prior to its release you can really say
oh this is going to go through the roof
we believed in the
talent and magical powers of mr
hitchcock
which proved to be correct and so
in that way i think we all felt we were
creating something
good i don't think no i don't think it
ever
crossed anyone's mind that it would have
that kind of impact
you